je n'en sais Go donc qui sont de nouveau
mot avec un dictionnaire du Petit Robert
en 2023 chaque année il y en a environ
200 alors gênant vous l'aurez peut-être
deviné c'est un mot familier qui définit
un sentiment de gêne de malaise éprouvé
dans une
situationnaire avant en fait non elle
n'est pas dans le dictionnaire le mot
goût lui veut dire jeune fille en argot
ivoirien il y a aussi l'expression
babtou fragile une variation de Toubab
entrée en 2014 une expression péjorative
qui fait référence à un homme blanc
européen qui se victimise les objets
numériques NFC et aussi rentrer en 2025
bravo
même les dictionnaires veulent faire du
buzz c'est incroyable non mais
franchement c'est incroyable c'est ça
c'est à dire que même les dictionnaires
maintenant il y a de la guerre des dico
et la guerre du boss dans les mots du
dictionnaire il se dit chaque année
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire rentrer pour
faire un petit peu de boss c'est fou oui
c'est ça ils sont obligés de faire du
buzz parce que maintenant on a tous sur
internet donc il a acheté un dico pour
personne donc ils se disent bon bah on
va rajouter des mots
ridicule on a assez de
je pense du monde comme ça pour combien
des mots comme ça dans le dictionnaire
par exemple
quoi c'est 2020 j'attends le 2023
je suis d'accord avec les académiciens
que j'ai écouté parler non que j'ai
écouté parler et qui disent que si
justement on veut qu'une langue reste
vivante ne meurt pas comme le latin et
d'autres langues il faut absolument
qu'elle continue d'évoluer et qu'on la
joue systématiquement
c'est ce que disait Gilles à son ex si
tu veux qu'une langue reste vivante
après le mot est à l'épreuve de des
feuilles à l'épreuve des angles bien sûr
il y a des mots qui vont rester et puis
d'autres qui vont disparaître au bout
d'un an deux ans
les [ __ ] ça veut dire quoi le mot
qu'on met dans le dictionnaire ça veut
dire quoi
dans 20 ans
il y aura un contexte ça veut dire que
j'essaye de te marcher dessus ça veut
dire que j'essaye de t'éteindre je veux
dire agile lâche-moi tu es un babtou
fragile c'est comme une espèce de c'est
comme si tu veux faire tu veux humilier
le mec ou tu veux le rabaisser et donc
et pourquoi ça ce mot-là il sera
d'accord
c'est ma meuf c'est ma femme exactement
achat du des mec dire babtou fragile
c'était pas positif
c'est plus intéressant
Kelly a dit la même chose que moi ça
vient c'est des trucs plus intéressants
et tu peux pas dire
non c'est vraiment un gars le petit
Robert
[Applaudissements]
et juste il exploite un univers il
connaît pas la définition du cinéma
d'accord avec Raymond et Kelly là vous
êtes
une expression
alors ils expliquent que c'est tout bas
ouvert et que quand on dépressive quand
on veut humilier quelqu'un en toi
d'accord
Gilles Verdez
[Rires]
mais c'est les jeunes les jeunes
mais moi je dis babtou brouteur tout ça
alors bien sûr brouteur il y a marqué
s'adresser à Daniel Moreau
[Applaudissements]
CF est-ce qu'on peut voir ce qu'on
pensait des spectateurs tiens si vous
avez fait un sondage si vous êtes
réveillé en régime s'il vous plaît merci
un problème technique
[Rires]
évoluent ça va permettre
aussi un parent ça va permettre aux
parents de comprendre le langage de
leurs enfants
à la fin du monde
faut pas dire lui lui il est noir lui il
est juif lui il a une expression
d'entre nous
ferme-la s'il te plaît merci quand je
dis stop c'est stop merci oui mon cœur
tu veux toi non je trouve que c'est ça
va permettre aux parents de comprendre
ce que disent leurs enfants aussi et
c'est très bien pour l'apparition de
nouveaux mots comme moulaga où tu es
malakishta c'est trop bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
êtes-vous choqué oui à 74% BIM voilà
voilà merci le public merci merci merci
les séries